1632 l'autre catholique des jésuites
banny purement et simplement
l'infiniment petit toute publication sur
l'infinitésimal était désormais n'ai
réussi sa décision avait des fins
politiques
un siècle plus tôt le prêtre chrétien
lutter vais déjà défié le pape sur des
bases théologiques depuis une vague de
protestantisme avaient envahi l'europe
et affaiblit le pouvoir de l'église pour
rétablir l'ordre dans la société de
jésus et rétablir l'ordre dans les
connaissances religieuses et
philosophiques
ils trouvèrent dans les mathématiques en
général et dans la géométrie d'occident
particulier quelque chose de robustes
dîner brand lab d'éternel vrai et juste
promu raincy l'enseignement des
mathématiques à travers l'europe avec un
air de c'était mieux avant donc arrêtez
vos conneries de réforme protestante et
revenons-en au fondement véritablement
vrai de l'église gary scott et de guide
sauf que les mathématiques ce n'est pas
juste consolidé des fondations les
mathématiques c'est avant tout un
domaine d'exploration et de création et
les mathématiciens de l'époque voulait
créer et explorer en particulier
l'infiniment petit même si ça des roches
complètement à l'ordre établi par la
géométrie d'euclide
ainsi des mathématiciens italien
rebelles comme galilée cavalieri et en
italie ne modère pas leur désir de
création et d'exploration il manipule l
infiniment petit ou infinitésimale
réussit ainsi à re démontré plus
succinctement de nombreux théorèmes
d'euclide mais les jésuites eu raison
des mathématiciens hérétiques de
l'époque et les mathématiques italienne
pourtant alors au sommet de l'art sont
très sûrement
c'est dans l'europe protestante que le
flambeau de la quête de l'infiniment
petit flux ravivé en tête de liste john
ou alice isaac newton et gottfried
leibniz a l'air bien plus loin que leurs
prédécesseurs et développeurs toute une
théorie du calcul infinitésimal qui
semblait désormais largement transcendé
la géométrie d'euclide cette théorie
mathématique se retrouve alors au coeur
de la première grande théorie
scientifique de l'histoire les lois de
la mécanique dont on a déjà parlé mais
même moins des contrées des jésuites
l'infinitésimal défier encore et
toujours l'intuition et pour cause
l'infinitésimal que la grèce notée x
était à la fois nul mais aussi plus
petit que n'importe quelle vraie
quantité étrange non
qui plus est ces quantités était
artificiellement ajouté en début de
calcul avant d'être supprimée au moment
de conclure
prenons un exemple calcul ou par exemple
des grecs sur des x ou y est égal à ixxo
carré pro line is d y est alors y plus d
y moins y qui est égal à 6 pouces dx au
carré - 6/4 et n'utilisant identités
remarquables on voit que ceci est égal à
x 40 + 2 x 2 x + 2 x carré - x carey qui
est égal à 2 x 2 x + 2 x au carré en
divisant par d'ex des deux côtés on
obtient des grecs sur dx est égal à 2x
plus dx sauf que nous pour conclure ce
calcul la glisse affirma qu'il fallait
faire disparaître les infinitésimaux qui
traîne ce qui nous donne en fait la
bonne égalité des grecs sur des x et hey
garad
2 x pour le puriste ces manipulations
était injustifiable mans injustifiée en
particulier georges berkeley fut
extrêmement critique envers newton et la
glisse appelant ses infinitésimaux les
fantômes des quantités défunte
ils sont là se manipule comme des vrais
quantité mais quand on cherche à les
observer
on ne les voit jamais
la glisse lui même ne reconnaissait pas
l'existence des infinitésimaux il
affirmé qu'il s'agissait avant tout
d'une astuce de calcul quoique cette
astuce semblait indispensable pour en
arriver à certaines conclusions mais arc
et il ceux ci n'étaient pas si différent
de l'utilisation des nombres imaginés
pour vous qui vivez au 21ème siècle
ceci ressemble beaucoup aux particules
virtuelles de la mairie un cantique ces
particules qui sont créés au moment des
interactions entre des particules et
peuvent pendant un court instant violé
des lois sacrées de la physique comme la
conservation de l'énergie mais qui
finissent toujours par disparaître avant
que l'on ne puisse les observe
quoi qu'il en soit les nombreux
disciples de la glisse à travers
l'europe s'en donnèrent à coeur joie
éprouvèrent des théorèmes spectaculaire
à l'aide de ces infinitésimaux en
particulier les bernoulli développèrent
le calcul variations elle est déterminée
à la porte qui minimise le temps de
parcours d'une balle en chute libre
alors que l'air lui invente al
exponentielle le gars rythme naturel la
fonction aux états et bien plus encore
mais ses succès remarquables étaient des
îlots dans des océans de paradoxes vos
contradictions et d'erreurs plusieurs
grands noms des mathématiques en avait
marre il voulait revenir au standard de
rigueur d'euclide et des jésuites et
militaires alors pour nous construire et
mathématiques qui à partir de fondement
indiscutablement véritablement vrai
ainsi le grand karl friedrich daoust
déclara-t-il je proteste contre
l'utilisation de l'infini qui n'est
jamais admissible en mathématiques alors
que le jeune nils abel affirme à l
exception des cas les plus simplistes
dans tout les mathématiques
il n'y a pas une seule série infinie
dont la somme a été déterminé
rigoureusement autrement dit les plus
importante partie des mathématiques se
tiennent sans fondations sur un château
de cartes que le vent peut emporter
dix neuvième siècle il devint de plus en
plus pressant de fortifier l'édifice
mathématiques augustin lui cauchy
entrepris alors un chantier en gommant
et en bannissant à son tour ses mots
disent infinitésimaux de ses
mathématiques il déclara ainsi la
renaissance de la rigueur en
mathématiques
sauf qu'après avoir longuement pester
contre le manque de rigueur son propre
cours d' analyse en termes de rigueur
arrivait à peine à la cheville d'une
vidéo cinq forums en effet ils
utilisaient des définitions comme on nie
qu'une suite tend vers zéro si elle
décroît indéfiniment vers zéro avec de
telle définition ce n'est pas surprenant
que cauchy a fini par prouver des
théorèmes faux fait pas comme cauchy à
l'école pourtant pendant près d'un demi
siècle
aucun mathématicien n'arrivait à la
cheville du niveau de rigueur de kochi
aucun mathématicien sauf un certain
bernard paul dano qui lui avait réussi à
re démontré toutes les découvertes de la
lgv nice et ce sans avoir jamais parlé
des concepts flous d'un film t.imo ou de
suite indéfiniment décroissante
le seul problème c'est que bolzano était
inconnu au bataillon
ce n'est qu'un demi siècle plus tard
vers la fin du 19e siècle que le
professeur de lycée karl mayer strass
pour redécouvrir la théorie de bolzano
et la consolidera enfin les
mathématiciens pur utilise un formalisme
solide qui bannit l'infinitésimal tout
en démontrant rigoureusement les
découvertes de l'avenir
c'est ce qu'on appelle parfois le
formalisme epsilon delta il s'agit d'une
définition d'une seule ligne tandis
qu'une suite tend vers la limite elle si
peu importe la petitesse de la déviation
epsilon par rapport à la limite
tous les éléments de la suite à partir
d'un certain rang se retrouve à moins
d'une déviation epsilon de la limite
elle cette définition pour moi c'est
vraiment le début des vrais
mathématiques pas celle qui consiste à
manipuler des formules dans tous les
sens mais c'est qu'ils cherchent à
s'assurer du bien-fondé logique de tout
ce qu'elle affirme sans jamais invoqué
deux concepts flous ou mal définis comme
l'infinitésimal j'ai mis beaucoup de
temps pour comprendre la beauté de cette
définition les mathématiciens eux mêmes
mis des siècles à la comprendre et à la
trouver
vraiment fondamental donc si vous
galérez à la comprendre si vous ne
trouvez pas vraiment encore utile c'est
parfaitement normal ne croyez surtout
pas que vous êtes idiots parce que vous
n'avez pas compris ça du premier coup il
faut du temps et moi il m'a fallu
beaucoup de temps pour internaliser
toutes les beautés de cette définition
et pour vraiment la sentir il faut du
temps mais si vous voulez vraiment aller
loin dans la compréhension des
mathématiques il faut absolument finir
par comprendre non seulement cette
définition mais aussi le pourquoi
l'utilité et surtout la beauté de cette
définition incroyablement élégante qui a
littéralement changé le cours des
mathématiques ou en tout cas les cours
de mathématiques
l'histoire des infinitésimaux ne
s'arrête pas là un siècle après le
triomphe des epsilon et delta de bolzano
every year strass dans les années 1960
le mathématicien abraham robinson
découvrir un univers mathématiques
mystérieux dans lequel l'infinitésimal
de lyme nice prenait tout son sens cet
univers mathématiques étrange que l'on
appelle analyse non standard est un
univers dans lequel toutes les
manipulations de la glisse celle que
font encore les physiciens d'aujourd'hui
sont en fait rigoureuse en un certain
sens en bref cette analyse contient un
ensemble de nombres ap les hyper et elle
qui est une structure plus fine que
celle des nombres réels en particulier
parmi les hyper réel il y à des nombres
strictement positifs qui sont plus
petits que n'importe quel nombre réel
ceci étant dit beaucoup de
mathématiciens doute de l'avenir de
cette théorie des nombres hyper réel et
craignent qu'il me reste voué à rester
dans les placards des mathématiques en
particulier cette théorie requiert un
niveau d'abstraction qui est largement
supérieur aux epci l'one est telle qu'à
de bolzano et valeur strass et il ne
semble donc pas possible ni pertinent de
l'enseigné à des étudiants mais qui sait
tant de génies se sont trompés dans le
passé sur le rôle qui était amené à
jouer c'est infinitésimaux la dernière
fois on a parlé du problème des maisons
numérotées de ramanujan et d'extraction
continue et en fin de vidéo nous est
notamment montré un petit passage de
matelot coeur qui parle de la fraction
continue qui décrit pi et montre qu'elle
donne des super approximations notamment
la première qui est 27e et hydroxy
chloride fait la remarque que son
grand-père utiliser justement cette
approximation pis à peu près égale à 22
7e en menuiserie et ce n'est en fait pas
un hasard si les fractions continue
donne deux superbes approximations en
fait on peut prouver que les fractions
continue lorsqu on les arrête toutes les
approximations des fractions continue
donne des approximations optimale en un
certain sens des nombres réels plus
précisément toutes les approximations
qu'on obtient avec une fraction continue
d'un nombre réel sont des approximations
tels que on ne peut pas faire mieux avec
un dénominateur plus petit que celui que
nous donne la fraction continue bâti
comme plusieurs autres parmi vous trouve
la solution de ramanujan déroutante
moi je la trouve archi déroutante je
suis content
perdu tout ceci en fait extrêmement
reliés à ce qu'on appelle les équations
de pelles ou parfois aussi les équations
de brana gupta qui sont des équations
qu'on appelle diouf ancien c'est à dire
des équations polynomiale plusieurs
variables en nombre entier donc si vous
voulez en savoir plus allez voir la
description de la vidéo précédente
enfin antoine de l'aga nous donne une
autre solution du problème qui est
absolument stupéfiante en fait je
comprends pas sa preuve nous donne une
formule est la formule marche qui veut
un petit peu les rames à nouveau avec
nous en plus je vais demander plus
d'explications et fait un petit peu son
malin genre du commentaires youtube sont
trop courts pour une démonstration ce
qui sera d'ailleurs
donc moi j'aimerais bien comprendre un
peu plus que sous-entend antoine
delaigue et donc je vous invite un peu
le spa menace pas misé un peu son
commentaire pour que pour forcer au
moins donner quelques sources pour nous
aider à comprendre ce qui se passe
derrière cette formule qui veut parce
que cette formule est vraiment
intrigante
j'espère que vous avez aimé cette vidéo
citée sur les infinitésimaux et
j'aimerais recommandé au passage un
livre qui s'appelle in fine tessinoise
raout entzheim des chips de modèles bold
qui est un livre plus d'histoire de
mathématiques
c'est aussi intéressant pour les
mathématiques et en gros la thèse de ce
bouquin c'est que cette étude des
infinitésimaux a été critique dans
l'histoire de l'humanité surtout de
l'europe aux xviie et au xviiie siècle
puisque à ce moment là le pouvoir était
vraiment en italie on peut penser à
marco polo et film bozotti
s'acquitter puissance économique
financière centrale et la renaissance a
fait partie du talent et du coup il y
avait une certaine avance au niveau de
l'italie également en termes
technologiques et mathématiques mais le
mouvement jésuites semble avoir
complètement ralenti ça en freinant
l'innovation alors que l inverse surtout
en angleterre et suite à la création de
la world society qui faisait la
promotion des débats et des choses qui
n'étaient pas fixées du coût de
l'innovation de la création bien ce
moment là notamment en angleterre de
mathématiques robes ou avec des gens
comme moi lycée newton roeck ou encore
pailhès et si on essaie de lire entre
les lignes de ce que sous-entend ce
bouquin peut-être que le fait que le
plus grand empire de l'humanité qui a
été l empire britannique
peut-être que l'hégémonie de cet empire
appuie la raison pour laquelle
finalement les états unis ce menu un pli
important et raison pour laquelle elle
augmente aujourd'hui et l'anglais c'est
peut-être parce que les anglais ont su
pousser la recherche sur les
infinitésimaux alors qu'ailleurs les
puristes dizaine en oman sail away from
her way jouera contre ça parce que je
trouve aussi très intéressant tout ce
que ça pose en termes de questions sur
la rigueur des sucres est ce que la
rigueur c'est important je pense que
cette histoire de l'infinitésimal en
tout cas voilà qu'on sait très compliqué
et des époques où un excès de rigueur
injuste freiner la recherche
et puis à linverse quand les allemands
le dix neuvième siècle ont voulu faire
preuve de beaucoup plus de rigueur
ils ont fait un élan nouveau nouveau des
mathématiques gauche
dunkin dirigeait kantor et d'ailleurs ce
triste pour mon bien traités
l'infiniment petit la planète vont à
parler d'un film en dessous on va parler
des nombreux transferts non puisque au
delà si vous avez aimé cet épisode
france est le laquais le commentaire est
le partage et pensez à vous abonner pour
ne pas motiver tous les épisodes merci
aux types comme nom et j'espère que vous
verrez la prochaine fois en amérique bac
est candidat